I promise you I'm gonna take from him
what he took from you you wanna kill
this guy I want him to suffer for
everything that he's done erase Barry
between you and me see who's the fastest
man alive
you want revenge if that's what you're
doing this you will lose
hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my flash finale trailer video just
careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the season so far cuz
we have to talk about what happened in
the last episode and there's some crazy
WTF the timeline of the footage isn't
super specific there's a funeral the way
they cut the trailer make it seem like
he has a small fight with zoom then
there's a time jump the funeral happens
then we see this final race you know
let's see who's the fastest once and for
all in what looks like the TV shows
version of the actual cosmic treadmill
the actual title of the episode is race
of his life
so that probably has something to do
with what zoom is using this giant
treadmill for now I'm just calling it
the cosmic treadmill who knows what the
actual name for it will be but that
might have something to do with earth to
being destroyed like Cisco sees in his
visions when I first heard cosmic
treadmill I really just thought of it
like in the original story of hunter
zolomon becoming zoom he gets on the
cosmic treadmill to try and go back in
time so that he can heal himself because
in the comics he lost the use of his
legs Wally West who was the flash of the
time and was his good friend refused to
change the timeline so zolomon attempted
to use the cosmic treadmill caused this
huge accident that gave him Speed Force
powers that they work a little bit
differently from previous reverse
flashes but this was all pre flash
rebirth wally west era flashed up this
was one of the last big Geoff Johns
flash runs before he did flash rebirth
Barry Allen came back and became the
main flash now there is a flash rebirth
happening next week but it's like a big
DC Universe rebirth it's completely
unrelated to what's happening on the TV
show but when you're thinking about
comic book stuff - flash TV show stuff
especially with cosmic treadmill zoom
versus the flash just think of imagery
the actual plot of a lot of those Wally
West's stories aren't going to be very
much like what they do on the TV show
the TV show is gone with different
characters so it borrows things from the
comics but usually it's just ideas or
names or characters they mix and match
things so what about Jay Garrick and the
man in the iron mask we were promised a
reveal we're gonna find out who's
underneath that mask I think we're all
hoping that it's the real Jay Garrick
and it's going to be played by John
Wesley Shipp remember his mother's
maiden name is Garrick
so even if it's not John Wesley Shipp
it's going to be someone from his family
Berry will probably be related to Jay
Garrick now keep in mind that it's still
an earth two person so there's all kinds
of twists going into season three and
it'll be really hard to guess the
direction they take it in season three
until we actually see what's going on in
the finale so let me know in the
comments do you think because they
killed off Henry Allen they're just
clearing the way for a John Wesley Shipp
Jay Garrick well you know whatever the
explanation is whether it's Barry's dad
from earth-2 or it's his grandfather or
some twist like that just keep in mind
that the actor who plays zoom said that
he's basically going to be dealt with in
the finale but he's not going away
completely it's kind of like the evil
bard dawn reverse-flash berry defeated
him in the season 1 finale but then we
saw him come back during season 2 so
zoom can always come back in the future
whatever the resolution is but a bunch
of different people from behind the
scenes like producers people associated
with the TV show have said that comic
book fans will really like what ends up
happening in the FATA the big twist so
that makes me feel like we're gonna see
the real Jay Garrick it'll be like Jay
Garrick rebirth like we saw Barry Allen
and flash rebirth and this big cosmic
treadmill is going to have universe
altering consequences now I don't know
how they're gonna integrate Supergirl
season 2 with earth 1 next year because
Cisco would still have to open a breach
to get to supergirls earth so they might
find some creative way around that if
there is gonna be some universe altering
consequence of this cosmic treadmill
race here then I think it's mostly gonna
be associated with earth 1 earth 2 but
just think about how they keep
broadening the mythology from season to
season on flash and arrow
they've already been teasing things on
legends of tomorrow things are getting
way more comic book II way bigger so let
me know what do you think the deal with
the cosmic treadmill is we've already
talked about Jay Garrick but now what
what is going to be the side effect of
them going crazy on this cosmic
treadmill here they'll probably be some
extra giveaways next week because of all
the finales because of all the rebirth
stuff happening so I'll try to think of
something cool and I will go ahead and
start a new round of the giveaway now so
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video if there's any other bonus videos
you guys want me to do next week just
let me know a lot of it will depend on
what happens in the finale like if we
see Jay Garrick I'll totally do a Jay
Garrick video but just make sure that
you don't wait to watch the flash and
arrow finales next week make sure to
watch them
the night that they air while you guys
wait for my next video to post you can
click here for this week's episode of
the flash and you can click here for my
Star Trek Beyond and Star Trek TV series
trailer there's a new Star Trek TV
series CBS is working on so thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight